and the bean protocol is all about fiber
it is all about soluble fiber and
getting any sort of toxins or excess
hormones out of your body and so if
you're dealing with
rosacea eczema if you're dealing with
infl infertility you're dealing with
acne it has a ton of
um a ton to do with the amount of
soluble fiber you're getting into your
diet i was always like well i get gassy
when i eat beans so my body's telling me
to not have these beans listening to it
so i thought what do i have to lose i
don't want to have acne anymore and i've
dealt with acne my whole life i've been
on accutane it comes back and i
obviously this is a hormonal thing
that's going on because when i go
through times of stress like when i
almost lost my dog
my acne goes crazy when i over exercise
my acne goes crazy so it's these
hormonal issues are going on
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
[Music]
i am happy to welcome my friend julie
bauer roth so i started following julie
years ago on instagram she's got great
workouts great recipes she's a really
like funny person as well i love the
fact that she swears on her social media
we finally hung out in person and i
really loved that i could sit down with
her and be able to talk to her more in
depth about food fitness and
spirituality so the really the way into
our friendship was the fact that she
talked about wanting to know more about
her past lives and i was like
dm i have a akashic reader if you'd like
to to meet that this person and use her
and she was like what's that and so um
but anyway she got an akashic reading
loved it and um but we we fit so easily
on so many different levels because
obviously i love food and fitness so
part of the conversation was about
working out and food and the workout
part that was so cool to hear is her
background in crossfit and working out
multiple times a day to stepping back
and doing like three workouts a week and
as she took down the load she actually
got she actually looked better she
leaned out she was able to you know
maximize muscle mass and she she just
looked much better and less inflamed and
so i was fascinated about that because i
am guilty of two days um but then we
talked about food too and just her
journey with all of it and and of course
spirituality which is something that i
just love to talk about if somebody is
interested so just somebody that fits me
on every level just really we just
really got along so well i hope that you
can find some some information
in the conversation that might apply to
you that might hit home
like it did for me so enjoy the episode
i
found you on instagram a long time ago i
don't know how long i've been following
you a couple of years probably that's
why i always wondered how you came
across my page in the first place i
don't know
because i remember getting tagged
in a workout you did one of my ab
workouts oh yeah and i was like
dude patrick shared one of my
workouts like she did my ab workout
and brian was like my husband was like
wait what i was like i know it's not
weird that's so cool
and then but i had no idea how you'd
even found my page in the first place
yeah well it i mean usually like
algorithm algorithms can be good they
can be bad but i'm sure that there's
probably some common people maybe that
we followed i don't know but i mean as
soon as i saw your page it was like
first off you're hilarious you're so
funny i love that you swear never stop
doing that
and um but your workouts are so good
your food is so amazing um and i just of
course love the holistic like lifestyle
so
um so i've been in i've been a fan of
your stuff for so long so it's so funny
that we're here sitting today because
i feel like i know you but i bet you
don't know me that well
well that is what's so crazy about the
internet is you can literally make
friends
with anybody around the world now and
you can find this commonality you can
find this friendship and literally go
travel to see them like you could go to
another country to see someone i feel
like i can go to any country now any
place and meet up with somebody who's
either traveling there or who lives
there
and they'll feel a connection if they
already follow me and then it's really
easy to get to know somebody because you
already feel like you have some sort of
bond or some sort of connection so the
time that we've spent this short amount
of time here it's just been like
catching up with a friend yeah like
getting to know each other but it just
feels like catching up with a friend in
the same way well according to our
akashic reader we do go way back in time
but we're not going to get to that yet
yeah um that's the next that's that's
the second part of this the first part
is the stuff that everyone knows you for
it's the stuff that i knew you for
um
and that's food and that's fitness um
and i totally
i'm such a stickler for form and i'm
like your form has always been
incredible i'm like this girl knows what
she's doing
yes i love hearing that so how i i'm
curious
how you even how you got into
was it food first was it fitness first
what was the impetus to really launch
you into
wellness damn i've never used the word
impetus i'm gonna add that to my
vocabulary now so thank you learning so
many things and so many words from you
so i
was definitely into fitness first i grew
up
hating myself hating my body hating just
like everything about myself it was so
sad and so
the first thing that i was introduced to
was fitness
and i started working out in high school
triple in a gym and so i'd go run red
rocks amphitheater um just to get
outside
and then
in college i would do you know two hours
on the stair master when you're like you
know oh i know hanging on i would do
that on the elliptical or
something like that and i laugh at
people now but
with love but i did it i can only laugh
at them because i've done it yeah and
you don't know what else to do yeah you
don't and
the weight room felt so intimidating it
was all good guys so i was too scared to
do that i didn't feel in shape so i
would just do elliptical stairmaster
bike
and then
in college i met a guy i started dating
this guy and he was doing crossfit
workouts and so he introduced me to
crossfit
i went on crossfit.com i couldn't do a
push-up i couldn't do a pull-up what
year was this then this would have been
2008
dang you got into crossfit og days oh
man they were still doing it at the
ranch back then yes they were and i saw
these crossfit females
that they would put they put a picture
every day with the workout back in the
day they put a picture up and it was
these incredibly strong females and so i
started i couldn't do any of those
movements by myself so i started going
to a gym where i couldn't find a little
corner and i would do push-ups on my
knees and then i would do the assisted
dip machine and the assisted pull-up and
start building up strength building
confidence in the gym
and then before i knew it i was at the
rec center at college and i was you know
doing overhead squats and i was doing
double unders and ring dips and it just
kind of grew from there
but what really stuck with me so much
with crossfit was i went to
crossfit used to have sectionals then
regionals and the games wow and so i
went to a sectionals in town i like uh
volunteered at this event
and all the women were so kind to each
other they were so there's so much
camaraderie yeah and kindness and
cheering each other on and i saw every
body type too there were really skinny
women there were really thick women
bigger like there was just every shape
and size and you thought like the woman
who looked the most in shape
coat in shape would do the best and then
it was a completely different person and
i just loved that about crossfit it
didn't it wasn't about how you looked it
was how you performed yeah and the
weight you got and the pr you got and
the time you got i just loved those
those new numbers instead of what was on
the scale totally and so crossfit just
hooked me in it got me i loved it i
joined a crossfit gym in college at the
end of college
i started competing and when i started
competing that's when i got into food
and crossfit was really big into the
zone diet
first yes really
i mean i only know paleo and crossfit to
be like boyfriend girlfriend but i had
no idea it was the zone so i think rob
wolf was really into zone back
and
so they had like a whole diet page that
was all about zone diet and have you
ever heard of zone diet of course yeah
like 40 30 30 yeah right like 40 40
protein 30 carbs 30 fat yes yeah and
you're getting you know your three
blocks or one block is like three
almonds one or one block is like one
macadamia nut and i still remember these
things because i packed little
containers of like almonds really here's
my box block of almonds here's my box
block of chicken yes and i would measure
out everything and that was the first
introduction to
healthy food yeah my boyfriend at the
time was jacked i'm like why don't i
look like you if i do the same workouts
as you yeah he's like well your diet is
[ __ ]
you
i have a terrible diet and i mean i was
eating the worst food you could eat
waffles for breakfast i would oh my god
i would eat literally animal crackers
like the coated frosted coated animal
yum with the sprinkles yes
with frosting danica with frosting with
frosting you're an overachiever
i already know that i know that about
you especially now but when i go hard
into something like eating bad i go hard
and so i got into the zone diet and i
started to lose weight and saw my body
change and i saw my performance increase
my numbers in the gym started going up
strength wise
and i just felt better i for once in my
life i didn't have a stomach ache i
didn't know what that was like i just
thought everybody had stomach aches at
all times right and gas and indigestion
it was just part of life and once i did
zone
that all ended and
then crossfit started getting in paleo
yep so i was like
crossfit i see you i'm in it i started
getting into paleo again i felt so much
better cutting out grains cutting out
gluten cutting out dairy my
body just felt so good yeah i just wake
up with so much energy for sure
and so
i competed in crossfit for years and
then while i was competing i was
creating recipes because i didn't know
how to cook at all so i just like wait a
minute you're creating recipes but you
didn't know how to cook those things
don't really go together that's true so
creating recipes is really hard for
people to think they can cook it's true
well i was like okay overachiever
i have to learn how to have banana bread
still got it and so then it's like oh
you can have almond flour you can have
coconut flour and that was back when
that stuff was really hard to get yes
like it's been it's only more recently
that you can find coconut flour almond
flour you know all the different flours
and the different fat even ghee i mean
like i don't even know if it was common
to find ghee and ghee you know because
ghee doesn't have the milk in it so
stuff like that was even not even that
common so yeah i would order a lot of
stuff online there was a website called
tropical traditions or nuts.com so i
would order stuff online
but whole foods would usually have
almond flour but it was like
i couldn't imagine it was so expensive
especially where i was out in life i'm
like how do i afford this
but i ate a lot of nut butter i baked a
lot of things with nut butter it was
like almond butter was my survival back
then yeah um and so i started learning
how to cook i would look at i would look
at magazines
and something that caught my eye i'm
like well how do i make that paleo and
so i would start seeing how they paired
ingredients together like spices
together or seasonings um how they
seared a steak i would kind of read up
on that and i watched the cooking
channel non-stop back then so did i yes
and you learned so much from watching
other people do it thanks emeril
augustine you started it off
yes
and like giada and even rachel ray
totally yeah her stuff was so simple you
could she's not even professionally
trained you know that yeah she doesn't
even she didn't go to culinary school
she just figured it out that just shows
like how much you can learn on the fly
and get really good at stuff and do it
constantly over and over you're going to
continue to get better at it with
anything in life
and i was sending all of my friends
recipes like texting them recipes or
emailing them recipes that i had made up
because that i would bring like these
no-bake cookies
or protein cookies they're like well how
do you make these and so i text them or
email them and then someone one day was
like you should start a blog and i had
no idea what a blog was
i had never even heard the word it was
so new back then yeah in 2011.
um
and yeah my friend literally was like
yeah i'll just help you set up this like
free website and just like got the
domain and helped me put up this little
crappy website and i just started
paleomg
wow yeah
so how often did you post on on the blog
so when i first started did you even
know what the hell 2 posts were you like
so what do i do with this thing i've got
it was so back then i was working at
five different gyms so
coaching right yeah yeah because you got
your crossfit light certification yes so
i went to school for health and exercise
science so i always thought i'd be
personal trainer own a team and so i
started working at a ton of different
crossfit gyms because you're not making
that much money so you've got to work
all over the place
and so i'd go from gym to gym and then i
would cook at night like in a crock pot
or something simple and i would take a
picture of it with my phone in
fluorescent light in our like crappy
kitchen
and just it was you know very simple
things like maple mustard chicken
um something in the crock pot like a
stewed beef some sort of pork i
was super broke that back then so it was
all very cheap cuts of meat sure stewed
beef yep and
but people didn't know what to cook when
they started with the paleo diet so
people would start in crossfit coaches
would recommend paleo and then you know
like what's that leo
and then my website would come up oh
really yeah because it was one of the
first ones yeah they didn't have any
other options did you did you do
anything to boost like it's because
can't you can do that kind of thing
where you boost its ranking right like
when people search for things was this
so was this completely organic this was
completely organic oh my god i don't
know how to boost anything let alone see
what is it
seo yeah yeah i have no i'm like seeing
ceo
i i don't know how to do any of that
back then it was literally just organic
people were going to it google was
ranking it highest because
there was just not many places to go
yeah
and there was like i know five or other
six friends through that community who
were doing the same thing so
none of us knew how to
uh photograph back then right we talked
about that and how fluorescent light is
like the devil yeah when it comes to
photographing food pretty oh my god
especially stewed beef in a crock pot
yeah just
looks like granu it just like harshly
brown yeah it's just a good old
pot of poop
so
i
just it organically grew and facebook
was very different back then so if you
came across the recipe and you shared it
on facebook your say your thousand
friends would all see the post and then
they would try it and so back in 2012 or
so i mean i was getting thousands of new
followers on facebook every day and it's
so different now
but it was just this organic growth
through crossfit and
the paleo community so
the name of the blog was paleomg right
away right yeah and that's still your
instagram handle yeah still but yet your
diet has taken like many like everyone's
diet i feel like even paleo i mean there
was a diet before paleo that we thought
was the best and then there was a diet
before that we thought was the best and
we're gonna think paleo was stupid
someday with some other diet i'm sure
totally and so you've gone through
different phases on that so before we
get into those things i i actually was
just thinking about this and i was
getting ready to do this with you i
haven't asked you this but you don't eat
paleo yeah necessarily anymore so
like probably quite a bit especially
because of the new bean protocol that
you do um but have you ever thought
about changing that
yeah rebranding i guess that would be
called rebranding essentially right yeah
so i've talked to my team about this who
rebranded my site recently
and
at this point literally all somebody
will see me on the street and say
paleomg they like don't always know my
name they know paleomg sure
and
so it's hard to let go of that identity
a little bit how and we've talked about
letting go of identities in general um
so i definitely plan to change the name
in the future i don't know what that
would be it would just be my own name
because
my llc is my own name so why not just
change it into that um
and that's what my site has really
become just things that i want to share
as a human being because it's not just
paleo food i mean you started with that
to help people but i mean that does
happen a lot where somebody
you know uses whatever they do as the
hook and then but you're that's not all
you are i mean you're everything from
food to workout to inspiration to
fashion i mean there's just so many
different aspects that it doesn't even
encompass everything that you do and
that you're into so that's a normal
that's a normal transition but it's also
a gamble
a little bit because you're getting rid
of the name everyone knows you for too
you know i know and so it's a hard it's
a hard thing to choose with the shift of
the name
i
i don't i just don't know would be it so
i think everything kind of happens when
it's supposed to happen and when
something feels really right i go for it
when it was back in probably i started
my blog in 2011 so it's crazy that i was
23 and now i'm 33 like the
transformation you have in your early
20s to your early 30s it's like
you can't believe how what how
small-minded you were yeah early 20s
yeah you've grown is a big growing phase
and i so i've listened to my gut with
many things and in probably 2013 2014 i
said i'm not going to just do recipes i
want this blog to evolve into lifestyle
whatever i want to share if i want to
share fashion if i want to share skin
care if i want to share
a really personal story that's affecting
me and may help somebody i want to share
that i'm not going to just keep it food
and so i listen to my gut when
something's pulling me in a different
direction and so i think my gut will
tell me when it's time to really shift
that name into something else yeah
but well maybe it'll be
maybe it'll be
being omg yeah
yes okay so you've done this being
protocol but before we get to like your
most recent sort of iteration was there
anything between going from zone to um
paleo to the bean protocol
was there anything in between that you
you lived in for a while that was
outside of paleo yeah so i did zone i
did paleo super strict and what were the
benefits first off because i think this
is interesting for people like what did
you notice with
zone then what did you notice with
paleo then what did you notice moving
forward from that
zone was portion control it just taught
you how much food you should be
consuming because if you don't know and
if you don't have a really good
um connection with your body and i
didn't because i was eating animal
crackers with frosting every day if you
don't have that real connection with
your body and how it should feel and
what hunger cues should feel like and
what fullness should feel like a zone
type of diet
or even weight watchers or any of those
can help you understand portion control
more so that gave me an understanding of
portion control paleo gave me an
understanding understanding of nutrient
dense foods
and what it was like to have different
types of vegetables and different types
of protein and what
organic and grass-fed and grass-finished
and pasture raised all those different
um ways
meat is brought into our lives um and
produce
it gave me a better understanding of
where our food comes from and the
importance of it and how it affects our
body
and
it it made me feel so much better
but what
was really lacking and i didn't
understand was fiber
and that was the biggest lacking in my
life and i didn't understand that for
years and years so once i kind of
stopped doing paleo because i just
didn't feel great and i didn't know what
it was
and
i was going through this big stage in my
life where
i was
uh over crossfit i was really inflamed i
was over exercising and i just didn't
feel connected to my body and so i said
am i allowed to cuss on this yeah okay
okay 100
okay
i said [ __ ] it i'm not i'm not doing
this anymore i'm going to do opposite of
what i've been doing for many years what
i thought was right and so if i'm on i
have french fries i'm gonna have french
fries um i still stayed gluten-free
because gluten-free just felt better
today or just we don't have the best
sources of grains unless you really know
where to look
um
and so i stayed gluten-free but if i
wanted french fries if i wanted a
dessert if i
um you know wanted to go eat out
somewhere i just let my life open up a
little bit more and had more flexibility
in it had way more potatoes because
white potatoes were so shamed in paleo
and then it kind of shifted when whole30
said potatoes were okay right so i
started eating more potatoes
um
my carbohydrates actually increased and
i felt better and so i just started
paying attention to my body more instead
of the really high fat diet that i've
been on before i went more higher
carbohydrate and that felt better so i
kind of just did this little shift
and then
years later so this was just um this
past year i was introduced to the bean
protocol through another podcast
and the bean protocol is all about fiber
it is all about soluble fiber and
getting any sort of toxins or excess
hormones out of your body and so if
you're dealing with
rosacea eczema if you're dealing with
infl infertility you're dealing with
acne it has a ton of
um a ton to do with the amount of
soluble fiber you're getting into your
diet so i started listening to this
podcast started reading up about the
bean protocol and it was all about beans
which i hadn't eaten in 10 years right
because of the paleo diet right and i
was always like well i get gassy when i
eat beans so my body's telling me to not
have these beans
listening to it
so i thought what do i have to lose i
don't want to have acne anymore and i've
dealt with acne my whole life i've been
on accutane it comes back and i
obviously this is a hormonal thing
that's going on because when i go
through times of stress like when i
almost lost my dog my acne goes crazy
when i over exercise my acne goes crazy
so it's these hormonal issues are going
on so i said [ __ ] it again and i'm gonna
eat these beans i'm gonna eat beans six
times a day
and it was did you start out at six or
did you start out with like once a day
and then twice a day or did you just do
the whole over a cheap you overcharged
over two you started with six six hard
so how'd that go so i first quit coffee
altogether which is already just the
most punishing thing ever it's so sad it
is so sad and so i started the bean
protocol eating beans six times a day
and i cut out coffee at the same time so
i was having a liver detox effect so
when you say six times a day like a
quarter to a third of a cup yeah i was
having about a fourth of a cup okay yeah
six times a day yeah and then i cut out
coffee so you have this liver detox
effect
while you're having the withdrawals from
coffee and it was it was wild because i
had crazy headaches and i never get
headaches but i also had pain near my
liver what this radiating pain and i had
full body aches like i had the flu
and i was like what is going on this if
this is just full um addiction to coffee
because i was having like one and a half
cups a day nothing like that's not crazy
and
that was a normal addiction to coffee
and yeah normal
and it made it made me like
question coffee i was like should i not
be drinking this is this is coffee gonna
be the new smoking in the future i mean
based off this there's like i remember
watching this program a long long time
ago
uh it was like drug something about
drugs and it was ranking schedules like
they have scheduled drugs and it was it
was way back in the day and it was
trying to decide which drugs fit into
which schedule of drug like legal
illegal which level and cocaine and
coffee were on the same level
and this is a long time ago so if my
memory doesn't serve me i'm sorry but
this is what i remember and they were on
the same level and then obviously one
was decided to be legal and one's
illegal
so you might be right maybe someday
coffee will be just like hard to find
and illegal and all of a sudden all
kinds of other stuff will be legal that
we never got i've never done cocaine so
i don't know if it feels quite the same
but i hope it was a little more exciting
than coffee but that i truly wonder if
that's not as enjoyable because
everybody loves to wake up with their
cup of coffee don't they it was so hard
to change over i was drinking drinking
like hot water with lemon
oh terrible terrible deer and it's also
so ritualistic you know i think there's
a lot of things that we do in our
patterns in our days that just like feel
like morning
they feel like a like afternoon lunch
snack they feel like friendship fun at
night they feel like friendship there's
like so much routine that we end up
liking and getting used to that make us
feel good and feel normal so wow you
just flip that upside down how did the
bean thing go was it comfortable because
like when i have beans too because i eat
paleo and have since 2000 and
uh well gluten-free dairy-free starting
in like 2013.
and then
paleo starting in 2000
was that 2016 beginning of 2016.
yeah 15 or 16.
it was rough
i farted
for three months and like thankfully we
were in quarantine at that point like
this was or not yes
like i'm gonna go take jackson for a
walk that's your dog um and we have a
long couch and so we can be on like
separate sides so i could you know get
away with it um it was definitely rough
i'm like is this ever gonna change yeah
and so there's a fermentation stage that
your body goes through with
beans and then once you get past it you
don't deal with that unless you have a
bean that just doesn't maybe work with
your system sure some are worse right
yes so chickpeas um garbanzo beans and
lentils are rough for me much more gassy
yeah but i'll play around with that and
test it out see if i can get away with a
little bit
but i still get what kinds do you eat i
do mostly black beans are like my
favorite they just work best for me
pinto beans
um cannellini beans
and butter beans those are the four that
i probably eat the most um and they're
easily
available you can find them pretty
easily
uh so i started eating beans this first
month i went i dove in i cut out the
coffee i started eating six times a day
and within two weeks my skin started to
clear up
and then within a month my skin had like
half cleared up
and then two months it just continued to
improve and not only did my skin
start to improve but i i honestly felt
leaner
and then my skin was like glowing
everywhere
it was it was crazy how big of a
difference that soluble fiber we should
probably be eating beans right now then
yes i mean you know i have a couple bags
of room i know i almost had some and
then i'm like well
i got them with me i always pack them
with me when i travel i like pack them
in my taxi most people pack like nuts
most people pack like you know bars you
got beans i got beans even there's like
these little i forget what kind of beans
they are but they're like a snacking
beans so they're like crunchy so you can
pack those
so i find little ways to get beans in as
much as possible i blend them into my
smoothies
and you can literally you just get black
beans or pinto beans and butter beans
rinse them off and then put them in your
smoothie and you cannot tell at all and
you just need like a fourth cup sure you
don't need a ton yeah and they just
blend perfectly in there does that help
make them make you less gassy too if
it's like
in a drink no just all the time i
haven't experienced that yet
it's about the same so the three months
came and then it finally cleared up like
you finally like your stomach was normal
yes it only took a month for your skin
to get better and for you to feel better
yeah but then three months three months
it was like my your i guess um
i think i forget what it was something
happens like your skin turns over every
three months or something like that
um so every three months i would see a
drastic change
and it would just get i'd get
tremendously better at three months
how i digested the beans and how my skin
looked and so now
my skin really pretty much only acts up
around my period whenever i just have a
hormonal spike but if you pay attention
to when your period is coming you can up
your bean intake to really help get
those hormones out of your body as
they're spiking before wow it's a
medicine yes it is and you can literally
do two like two tablespoons of beans
every hour every two hours just to get
extra in just to help
because what happens is the hormones
attach to the beans and i'm totally
butchering this like please people if
they're listening to us lisa listen to
the professionals who karen heard or you
need cam and they know what they're
talking about um but the
hormones bind to the beans and then
you're able to obviously excrete them
and so the more you get beans into your
diet throughout the day the more
availability it has to clean the
hormones to cling to beans and then you
can get rid of them
so you want to make sure people ask like
well can i just eat like one big serving
a day but if your goal is to really help
with those hormonal issues you want to
get them throughout the day kind of
every hour every two hours or so
what other kind of things do you have
that are not paleo
um that don't they don't bother you
rice i do a ton of rice i love rice um
we had black rice last night i never
cooked black rice and it was delicious
yeah um
i'll do gluten-free bread sometimes
um some different types of chips
uh
[Music]
those are the main things yeah i try to
stay away from sugar yeah just because
it doesn't make me feel good and
will cause more skin issues so there's
the main things is some gluten-free
stuff and when i eat out more if um if
we're on vacation and there's something
i want to try i'll always try it they're
just some things like fried food i don't
crave fried food right i don't taste the
same yes
and it's just like
sometimes nice to have that crunchy
outside on some things but
like last night there were tempura fried
um
blossoms available and then she said it
was a gluten-free flour and then i
almost wanted to get it yeah but it
still just has that oily yeah coating
that kind of gets in your mouth so
other than that i'll always she said it
was chickpea and then i went oh boy
that's not a good idea i know i know it
was like gluten-free chickpea oh well i
know i bet those are so good they
probably were so good maybe we should go
back yes that place was really good yeah
the food and the food here is so amazing
so the other thing was that gives you an
indication through your skin is too much
working out and so this is where when
you were on your way here and i'm like
you can help me learn how to take rest
days and so i'm so fascinated with the
physical journey of going because i'm
right with you at like crossfit like
multiple workouts a day
and just you know
thinking that since i can i should
and
the real truth is is that i really can't
and nobody really can it's not it's
totally detrimental to your health and i
mean i think even crossfit themselves
knows that like games athlete level
people like that's not real crossfit
like that's not you know like you said
there's all kinds of body shapes and
sizes out there um so it's not about
training like that it's about
being fit for life and that's one of the
things with crossfit that i respect is
that they really really originated with
learning how to move your body and being
able to move your body so that for the
rest of your life you can do things like
pick up a box and that's a deadlift and
then reach for something and that's a
pull-up and then you know there's just
it's meant to be very functional and
being not necessarily the best in any
one area but good in all of them
and um so i'm right there with you with
with loving crossfit and loving so much
about it there really are so many great
things it's so encouraging and it is
nice to be in an atmosphere where you
know
it's you're celebrated for being strong
instead of celebrated for being skinny
yeah and um i i like that too
uh but there is some downsides and it's
it's not my sister said it best we went
and got our level one years back we went
and did it at the ranch which was really
fun
and we were on our way to the
the the um the certification and she
goes you know
it's not crossfit that gets you hurt
it's your ego and it's like 100 so true
because i mean the class itself is you
know not super overwhelming sometimes a
workout can be but it's the fact that
you're like i could do more that gets
you yeah so between that and then
learning how to take rest days like this
big arc of four like three four workouts
a day two
three four workouts a week i wanna hear
how you did it and how you trusted it
and then all the things that happened
because
i think there's probably a lot of people
out there that suffer the same thing
and um and also then you know even from
my own journey as i've shared with you
some of the more personal like things
that i'm i'm testing out and doing and
i'm gonna talk about that myself on a
whole solo episode about all the things
that i've been doing but just how
um
sometimes when things aren't going right
you think i'll double down on this or
i'll double down on that and that kind
of exponentially makes things worse and
so i just think that it's such like you
thank you for doing this so that i can
listen and learn yes
that's what i think is
when you start crossfit
you get some crazy results you do
physical results strength results
totally it's like within a year or two
you're like this is the coolest thing
ever yes
every day you go in and you are able to
do something new depending on how
consistent you are if you are very
consistent if you're going five six
workouts a week you are seeing big
strength increases you're getting your
first pull up maybe you're getting a
muscle up or ring dip like you're just
able to do something new all the time
so where your mind goes if i can get
this much out of six workouts what if i
do two a days well okay i can do a
strength session and then a crossfit
class and that's where i started when i
was still in uh college i would do a
strength
portion in the morning at the crossfit
gym they let me come in and just do my
strength portion and then
i would go to a crossfit class at night
which usually would include some sort of
strength and then some sort of metcon
afterwards and so i start doing two days
and
lo and behold more results right like
okay this is awesome cool so then
putting the work in getting rewarded yep
and then i was competing so
i just wanted to get better and stronger
i didn't have any coach telling me how
to do it so i was like well i'll just
figure it out on my own and i also
worked at five crossfit gyms so what
happens when you work at crossfit gyms
is people ask you to work out afterwards
there's other coaches around and so
they're like hey do you want to go do a
workout now like yeah i do so sometimes
i i was doing four workouts a day and
then my rest days i felt very guilty
about resting and so i'd run five miles
i would do row sprints i would do uphill
sprints and so my rest days were active
rest days body weight workouts
and i was never resting i was just
completely beating my central nervous
system down never recovering
and
but i was getting results i was
continually lifting heavier and i hadn't
hit the wall yet and i competed in
regionals in 2011 and then did better in
2012 i put 30 pounds on in a year by
simply [ __ ] working out all the time
yeah and
then i got 11th in 2011 and then 8th in
2012 and so some improvement
and
then in 2000 right after that regionals
i injured my shoulder in a workout
and that was my first like big injury
where it was like okay something's weird
how did i do that what were you doing a
snatch it was a one-run max snatch in a
competition and so i injured my shoulder
and so that kind of pulled me back a
little bit
and then i would look in the mirror my
acne was out of control i mean it was so
bad cystic acne all around my face i was
30 pounds heavier i literally looked in
the mirror and i remember crying my face
off because i'm like i don't know who i
am i don't recognize myself who is this
person
and now i'm thinking
what i'm whatever i'm doing is not
working
so i need to do the opposite
but my identity is crossfit
i am crossfit i've created that i am
paleo
and so
saying that i'm not that anymore when
you when you're younger you're so
attached to
um identities
and so to say that i'm not a crossfit
intern anymore was like no way could i
do that yeah so i was like okay i'm just
gonna cut back and you loved it it
wasn't that you hated crossfit loved it
right i love it you know i coached
full-time
and
i you know was known for that in the
community and all my friends were
crossfitters i met my husband at
crossfit like my whole life was around
it
and so
to say that i'm not going to go to the
gym as often was really hard and it was
really it made you feel like you were
lazy
when i'm saying like okay i'm only going
to work out once a day
and i said it four times i get it
like
i like to think that i went from maybe
21 workouts a week to five workouts a
week like that's a huge difference yes
so i was like okay no you're gonna stick
with it you are going to lift lighter
because your body aches everywhere and
you have injuries and you are going to
do way less workouts and you're going to
stick with this and i i cried through
workouts because the coaches and my
friends there would be like why aren't
you doing 95 pounds
why are you using 365 yeah why are you
rxing it why aren't you why why aren't
you rx plusing it yes
and they're like no put more weight on
the bar and i was like come on julie you
know you can do more yes and these were
people i looked up to and they were my
peers
and they're like julie come on don't
don't do that you're a coach you need to
do prescribed and i would cry through
workouts knowing that i could physically
do do something and i wasn't doing it so
and i but i told myself i'm gonna do
this and so i started trying other
workouts too i'm like okay maybe i need
to do more uh cardio based stuff and so
then i started doing orange theory
you know same hit style training
longer workouts but very high intensity
um
did you notice a change when you started
sort of shifting the programming no okay
i didn't see a change i felt more so
like
it was leading to injuries because it
was like non-stop running sure going
through
tons of repetitions
so
but i just was trying to find my new
thing my new identity i just needed to
find a new identity and so orange theory
didn't work i tried pilates i tried have
you ever tried a versa climber class no
but i've tried versaclimber for sure yes
i've definitely used the verse clamor
they're very did that they're brutal
brutal but you you're so addicted to
pain
and yep putting your body through pain
and you think that if you didn't work
that hard and you're not drenched in
sweat then you didn't really work out
yeah that you're not getting anything
you're not going to see change
and so
it was step by step i started
decreasing my weights more and more in
crossfit and
it took me three years but i lost 30
pounds in three years that's amazing i
simply yeah cutting back which is like
normal weight loss for a human being
and
just by slowly cutting back in weights
and being more lenient with my diet
because i was like eating a ton of nut
butters because
you know that was kind of where paleo
was at sure
nut butter doesn't work well for me and
my skin issues so why am i doing this
i'm gonna have some more potatoes
instead of having a higher fat so do you
think there was a big calorie shift or
do you think it was just
some sort of energetic freedom food
freedom i think both you know because
like it's one thing to change the food
and be like not mentioned that you're
eating drastically less calories or or
less calories um but sometimes i think
there's some energy behind it too of
just not getting attached too much not
thinking so much about the weight and
more about the
um
enjoyment more about the freedom less
punishment more flow well and it's less
cortisol then because you're not
stressing yeah so that's what i think
was one of the main things i definitely
obviously calories
are a huge part of
uh weight loss but i think that shift in
uh stress hormone that happened in my
body by working out less and by
stressing less about food yeah because i
just i stopped thinking about it all the
time it didn't consume my entire day
and
so i slowly started losing weight
feeling so much better i would wake up
without aches and pains
and then
the less i did crossfit the better i
felt
and the more i wanted to try different
types of workouts so i wanted to try
more strength based workouts so i
started doing more bodybuilder style
workouts where you're doing a 3x10 or a
3x6 or a two by twelve
very simple things where i'm not
increasing my heart rate
that much you know you get a little
spike and then it comes back down but
it's not crossfit where you're tasting
blood in your lungs
where you have to lie on the floor
afterwards you're more so like oh oh my
butt's cramping a little bit
your legs are feeling tired right but
you're never laying on the floor
acting like a dead fish you know like
wailing in pain
and
i started doing that and i continually
felt better i didn't have pain in my
traps anymore which i had had for
seven years i didn't have any had traps
too yeah because when you clean the bar
and you pull it up
constant cleaning constantly actually
since i've done less crossfit too
because i really haven't been to a
crossfit class and
it doesn't mean i haven't done crossfit
moves i mean i still clean the bar i
still i mean you still do some of that
stuff too um but i don't do crossfit
exact like only and it's probably been
what was that it's probably been since
the beginning of 20 so it's probably
been a year and a half
and one of the things i noticed is that
when i put my um
purse on my shoulder with the strap
it doesn't just fall right off because
when your traps are so big things just
slide right off yes
yes i was thinking about that the other
day that's like so funny
my strap stays on my shoulder now yeah
yeah like you're
you get huge traps of crossfit because
there's so much pulling motions like you
just do so much pulling and i
noticed as i started getting into these
different style workouts so much what
was lacking in crossfit like a lot of
unilateral movements a lot of lateral
movements yeah i
had really not much strength in my inner
thighs and outer leg like i just was
missing a lot of strength in my glutes
and i started doing a lot more glute
work because i just wanted to build a
bigger butt but it really improved my
squat i didn't have hip pain anymore
that i had had during crossfit so i was
seeing these really great improvements
from doing less crossfit
and then i would go to a class and just
drop into a class
and i have
a competitive nature just comes back and
i don't i don't want to lessen my weight
i don't want to reduce my weight
and i don't want to be last and so i
push it really hard yeah and we talked
about this so it's so hard you go in
there and you're like you know it's like
an addict and you're like
oh i can totally do bar muscle ups i
haven't done them in a year and a half
but why not yeah let's do it like the
open came about this year and it was
like the open had a had a um a clean and
jerk and then bar muscles up in the same
workout it was like something with bar
muscle ups and then afterwards you had
to find your one rep max for a clean and
jerk and i was doing bar muscle ups and
i mean i can do them but i hadn't done
them in at that point like i don't know
a year and um or nine months at least or
something like that maybe over a year
because i had done a lot less hanging on
the bar even when i was there at the end
because i felt like my upper body was
just so built yeah and uh
but i was like screw it it's the open
and i was by myself so imagine what
happens when i go to an actual actual
gym and i get like you know
prodded into or like my own guilt really
it's not anybody else always and i did
them and i i did the clean and jerk too
and i was surprised that i did i think i
got like 135 for the 130 for the clean
and jerk and i was surprised yeah
because it's pretty close to a one rep
max for me ever
and i but i still reported back to my
girl my my sister brooke and my other
friend aaron who were all really into
working out together um and we're doing
the boston marathon together so we love
working out and i told i texted him
afterwards and i was like guys i forgot
how to crossfit
like i sucked at my bar muscle ups i was
like you know
but it gets so easy to get pulled back
in
and you don't i don't know if you were
like this but i don't like disappointing
people sure so when a coach who i've
been friends with for years and who i've
looked up to and we've had a great bond
when he says you should do this i don't
want to let him down sure and even i
have a personal trainer now and he'll
put a weight on the barbell and i'm like
i can't do that and i know in my head i
can't do that but i'm gonna try because
i don't want to let him down and i know
he's watching and i do really well with
an audience which is probably why i'm on
social media all the time but i am i do
great with an audience and i don't do
great without an audience unless you
just need me
well or one person i should say yes i
mean i just need an audience i mean
dog's here too
she's doing great you're doing great
ella yes i'm performing for ella all the
time
and so i i don't want to let anybody
down and i definitely don't want to let
myself down and so
when that workout comes up and i know i
can physically do it it's going to suck
and i'm going to pay for it
i'll do it and so i kind of have to stay
out of crossfit all together
to
not get pulled back in there because the
community is so beautiful yep i i loved
going to the gym i would be in the worst
mood i would be devastated something
happened crying and i would walk into
that gym and all the weight was lifted
off my shoulders it was just
such an amazing community and i think
people feel that way everywhere in
crossfit you've been to a gym that you
haven't liked and you've been to a gym
that changes your life yeah for the
better yeah and crossfit really did it
changed my entire life for the better
and
i will still go back to it once in a
while yeah um i don't need it in my life
now but it
will change people's lives in such
impactful ways whether that's the people
they meet whether it's the workouts they
do whether it's just the community
that lifts them up in times of pain and
i've seen them you know put on uh
fundraisers together for people in the
crossfit community what's going on like
totally it's such an amazing community
yeah and i got to be part of that and oh
i love it it's hard
it's hard for us over achievers to uh to
just do the one class yes
it is and then just anyone but so where
have you landed now where's your where's
the happy place now with the amount of
with the frequency and then the style of
workouts yes so you know i was working
21 workouts a week or so and then now
i i work out with a personal trainer
twice a week um because we have a home
gym at home but it's so nice after
especially after a year of not seeing
anybody not being in gyms
getting back into a gym atmosphere after
i coached in one for seven years six
seven years
i couldn't wait to get back to a gym
where
i could see the same people all the time
i could make new friends
and i could also not have to program for
myself and i have to tell myself what to
do
i just walk in and someone has already
done it for me because you make up
workouts all the time i mean on your on
your page you know you have tons of
workouts which i've used so many times
for inspiration so cool um and i've
loved them when you were like one of the
first ones that started that i was
following that started breaking it up
into little videos to show the moves and
i was like thank you finally yes when
you'd have to wait for the move to come
right one video and we just nobody has a
patience to last for a whole minute so
i'm like i just need i just need three
seconds three okay got it yep okay got
it um so um which is super cool you led
the way for me well that's learn but
that's awesome i program for workouts on
instagram just to give free workouts i
um program workouts for myself for
testing programs and then i
create fitness programs and so have
somebody program for me is like thank
you and yeah and fill in the spots that
i am lacking because i have so much to
learn still and as we've talked about
you can learn something from every
single person you meet yeah and there
are far better trainers out there than
me and so i found this trainer who
through a friend who he actually went to
the same program as i did at csu at
colorado state um and he is a phenomenal
trainer and i've learned so much from
him and i've experienced so much and
i've created such a strong friendship
with him as well that it has brought so
much joy into my life and so i train
with him twice a week i train at my
house once or twice a week and then i go
to um pilates which is right next door
to the personal training studio um just
to do something totally different that
feels
so foreign and so
weird because it's so different than
strength training
um and then i also in the summers i run
red rocks because i just like being
outside and just doing something so you
do like five weeks five workouts a week
yeah and then in the winter i was doing
three for a while um if i'm stressed i
cut back on my workouts got it yeah
don't work out more which you know we've
been told you know crossfit or crossfit
working out as a stress reliever because
you know brings to endorphins well if
you're stressed you're putting your body
in another state of stress so you're
just doubling that cortisol i mean if i
got tired ever like in the past 10 years
or maybe eight years at least if i was
tired i'd be like
i'm just gonna go work out i know
that'll wake me up
yes i didn't sleep i didn't sleep i
would go do more is that funny yeah and
we i don't know if it's just our
american community i don't know if it's
like that around the world but we're
just talk we're taught to um work harder
at all times work and then work harder
and if you are not the person who sleeps
the most the smallest amount of time
yeah does multiple workouts a day well
you're the lazy one yeah and nobody
wants to be the lazy one
and so if you're an overachiever you
definitely don't want to be
and so it's a really hard shift to go to
go from multiple workouts a week to just
three but i found the more i rested the
more results i was getting because i was
building this muscle but i was creating
all this inflammation and i was constant
constantly inflamed yeah and as i rested
that inflammation went down and then i
would see this like new muscle in my leg
or see this new muscle in my arm or see
my core more like i was finally able to
see these results
all by resting so i was like okay
i'm gonna stick with this that's amazing
so you have but and you have workout
programs we were talking about this
today on our on our hike but you have
six programs well how many cookbooks do
you have you cook books workout programs
like if people are interested in
following along with one of your
programs or
part of your food journey
where do they find that so i have three
cookbooks you can get them all on amazon
barnes and noble like all those kind of
different book sellers um those came out
in 2013 14 and 15 i kind of did three
back-to-back and then this past year in
2020 i started launching fitness
programs and that's what i always had
wanted to do since i was going to be a
personal trainer that i was always going
to be in the fitness space i had
programmed workouts for myself for the
gym and so i always wanted to create
fitness programs and then i found the
right team to really be able to launch
it in the way i wanted to
um and so i think i have six
uh maybe seven and then i might be i'm
launching my eighth which is going to be
my um
uh
my next program's three times a week
it's going to be my align program and so
it's really just aligning your life that
you can enjoy your life get a great
workout in and then live the rest of
your life without having to obsess about
getting five workouts in a week because
that's really challenging for a lot of
people yeah and most of my programs in
the past have been five workouts a week
and that's just sometimes people can't
fit it in and they feel guilty about it
so i created a program that people could
fit into their weekly schedule whether
you're a busy mom whether your job is
all over the place you're a doctor you
work nights you're able to get these
three workouts in that are going to be
full body workouts that are going to
really push you in the gym and get a
great workout in but they're not going
to destroy you either so you can't work
out the rest of the week or can't do the
things you love like go hiking or
go biking or whatever so yeah it's
evolved from cookbooks to fitness
programs yeah
yeah and it's going to continue to
evolve because
i have no doubt that there'll be some i
don't know how it's going to come in or
what the what the realization of this
new phase is going to be but the reason
why we're here is today and like
actually together is because of
connecting more on the spiritual journey
and i remember it was the i think you
said it was like christmas time or
something like that you posted something
about wanting to know
about past lives
and i had maybe it was because i had
tagged you in a workout maybe we had had
a dm or two before that but i don't
think we had talked that much no but i
just reached out and said have you ever
had an akashic reading and you're like
no but what they what is this and so i
had had one just recently and so i had
an akashic reader for you if you if you
wanted one and so anyway fast forward
and then i i followed up and i said
something like did you ever get that
reading and you're like no but thanks
for reminding me let me book that
and then you booked it right then and
you like to send a message when you
booked it for you like done it's the
24th whatever yeah and um and then you
had it done and and that kind of led to
more conversation because of
you know it's something that a lot of
people don't know as much about about me
i think they have a good indication now
if they follow me enough but if you
haven't and you only know me as a race
car driver you probably have no idea i'm
super spiritual and i'm super into
um quantum physics and the nature of
reality and and all of that stuff and so
but but we've connected on that and this
is such a fun phase because as we've
been talking since you got here about
all these different things you're like i
don't know about that yet and there's
like so many different uh rabbit holes
we can go down um and so you there's so
much coming there's gonna be so much
coming at you and so much change too i
should say that like it you can't your
old life your new life is gonna cost
your old one so in some ways there will
be transitions and it might show up
through
i mean for everybody it's different it
shows up through work it shows up
through relationships friendships family
um it show but it can show up through
you know might this might be the
manifestation shift of your name
changing first for your social and for
the business things like that could
shift as you enter into this space more
and grow and expand and really like
um you know
i don't know the right word it's like
i mean change yeah it's change right
change yeah so what um
like what on like what gave you this
curiosity about any because there's
sometimes there's something that happens
that you know you watch something you
read something and all of a sudden or
maybe you have an experience with you
know relationships and
you know traumas and things like that
but like what was it that made you
interested in spirituality and wanting
to know more about everything from past
lives to
um reality to uh you know the spiritual
world so the first thing that happened
was i went to bali
and my girlfriend jess i met my friend
jess there and she said hey would you
guys be down for an astrology reading a
birth chart reading
i booked one for you just as like a gift
i booked one for you and brian your
husband and i think it'd just be really
fun she did mine and it was really cool
and so we met up with this astrologer at
a little restaurant we were in like a
little loft area
and she uh read i think brian's first
and did you sit there for it yeah
because that's like kind of interesting
because it's it can be a little personal
i know and that's i've heard that with
people but we had no idea what was going
to happen sure i knew nothing about
birth chart readings nothing okay i knew
i was a taurus that's it i didn't know
what brian was i didn't know anything
about astrology so
she definitely i'm sure she held back
with a couple things like just knowing
we were together yeah and you know she's
told me kind of some stuff over time but
she um
she read brian's i think first and then
she read mine and she was spot on about
the relationship with my mom
about um my fears of getting being
pregnant or having a child um she was
spot on about my job she was like it's
showing that you like have um like an
obsession with food but you should
definitely be in business with food is
that like what you do like
oh my god yeah right and then um she was
like you should be in publishing and
i was like well i've already published
three cookbooks and she's like you need
to keep publishing and then then i
publish all my fitness programs um and
so she just had all these things that
were like
insanely spot on it blew my mind i
started crying at one point i was like
was she american or was she she was from
new zealand okay she was new zealand
yeah okay so that i mean like it's not
like she follows you and could like you
know i mean she could have from new
zealand but a less likely chance very
less likely like it was in bali she gave
you know jess gave her my name like she
would have been very hard to look up and
know all the personal stuff about
children and my mom you'd have to do a
lot of re research to dig into a podcast
to find that out sure so um and then she
had same sims
similar stuff with brian like really
spot on stuff and so i went back just
like my mind blown from it i was like
that was so insane and i started kind of
getting into astrology started just
looking at very you know
nothing like crazy just like the fun
stuff online yeah reading more into that
and then
uh my friend jess again she just always
looks up these different things she
found out about a marconic reading
which
is so it's this spiritual it's very much
a
spirit uh a healer kind of talks to your
spirit guides so you're lying on a table
kind of has like a reiki type
vibe to it um and then she talks to your
spirit guides and then she tells you
what they said
and that was another one where um she
asked if i she's like i see you as a
person who inspires others they're
saying like you're a person who teaches
others how to do things like and she
asked what i did and i told her i was
like in fitness programs and stuff like
that and she's like you know i see you
being more of a mentor role in the
future and then i had another reading
somewhere else and they said like a
mentor role so
these like kind of similar things kept
popping up
and
then with the
i i just started feeling more like i
have past lives i don't know what made
me feel that way if it was just
something i read and it just connected
with me i think one of my girlfriends
once said um you know there's the idea
that we have past lives and then we have
the same uh social group that we did in
past lives so if you you meet someone
and you feel connected to them right
away it's because you were connected in
a past life and that just stuck with me
for some reason and connected with me
and i loved that idea this fast forwards
to the beginning of the conversation
when i said in the past lives and of
course it's felt easy because we were
together in past lives which is what the
akashic readers told you about us yes
because we have the same reader yes
so then
you reached out about the akashic
reading and i've just been open to try
anything and everything sure because i
get monthly forecasts from my astrologer
from bali every month she does a birth
chart little reading just a small 10 15
minute recording of what's to come and
it was funny because i was trying all
these
uh different reading sessions and she
told me in one of my calls recently that
this year is going to be big for
spirituality for you so be really open
to saying yes to anything trying
anything oh boy and so if something
comes up i'm like yes so i booked a
reiki session i booked the akashic
reading i just booked a tarot card
reading
and i'm just finding what connects with
me
because i was never raised religious i
didn't connect with
organized religion i never understood it
i went to church when i was a little
younger tried it out and i was like
this doesn't make sense to me and just
like someone would feel that way with
spiritual with uh an akashic reading or
a past life or a different idea they're
like that doesn't make sense to me
organized religion never makes made
sense to me
but i've wanted
for this past year i've wanted to find a
deeper connection to the world around me
why am i here what is my purpose where
did i come from what is my journey after
this and i may never know the answer
solve that but why not try start digging
just like people dig into history why
shouldn't i do that the same way in my
own way
and when i had the akashic reading she
was like oh yeah of course you and
danica get along you have the same you
have a very similar past life
experience
and
she had some incredibly spot-on things
about
just me as a person
i asked her if i would ever have
children because i've always questioned
that and she she laughed and she's like
oh yeah she's right here and my
astrologer said that you're going to
have a daughter someday it's a feminine
energy
isn't that crazy when you like talk to
them they're like oh yeah they're right
here and you're like
what do they look like then what do you
mean like holy crap you know you just
want to like tap into that right yeah so
matter of fact and she
she was such a warm and kind
oh she's so sweet yeah her energy is
great
and she just had this spot on spot on
over and over but then it also made me
as soon as i got off the phone with her
i was like i'm going to start meditating
she just said something that connected
with me i'm going to start meditating
i'm going to start journaling i'm going
to start looking at crystals and so all
these things have just been little
stepping stones of trying things that i
don't know anything about
but what if something connects with me
and what if something helps me get a
better understanding of where i came
from and who i am and what my future may
look like and
purpose like
it gives me more purpose to be an even
better person and to have empathy for
people because it gives you a more
connection to the world around you yeah
and people who are going through the
same struggles with as you are but in
different ways
and when you get attacked online or a
person is mean to you in a grocery store
line or cuts you off in traffic it gives
you empathy for the person and
compassion for the person and the
struggles they're going through and
that's what spirituality has given me as
i'm on this very early new road
and where is this going to take me
business-wise where is this going to
take me and my relationships my
friendships right but it's given me
compassion for the world around me which
is has that been the main shift that
you've felt so far yeah yeah so like how
is that showing up in your life
differently now
i felt very defensive online before
where i had to always defend myself when
someone said something negative or prove
myself right or act like i knew
everything and now i can just be like
what is that i've never heard of that oh
i've never heard a word that word i
don't have that vocabulary oh you don't
like me that's okay
not everybody's gonna like me and
i hope that whatever you're struggling
with
that causes you to lash out at me i hope
you get through that
and it's just it's opened me up to
understanding that we are all human
beings learning things and figuring
things out and that's okay if we don't
know everything
and it's actually a really beautiful
thing that to know that we know very
very very little and we have so much
learning to go yeah so that's what i've
gotten from spirituality and i can't
wait to see where it takes me in what
direction and
you know if it takes me into travel if
it takes me into different experiences
have you heard
i mean
what do you think it's going to be like
because i'll
what do you think it's going to be like
the the path of spirituality yeah
um
oh man i want now i want to know what
you think it's going to be because
i think i'm going to dive deep
i think i'm going to it's going to cause
me to travel different places and do
things on my own i think i might do a
meditation retreat
um a lot of breath work
different experiences that give me
a different feeling of tapping into my
inner soul a little bit more
um
but i don't i don't know long term
well
have you ever seen those memes on social
media where by the way you're never
going to stop i mean once you've started
now it's it's very very uncommon that
someone ever stops the ball rolling once
you get it going in the in this aspect
of growth i mean it's really about
growth but i think and i think that
and i hope i don't make anyone mad but
you know i think spirituality is is kind
of the
the word for kind of in including
everything like
yeah i feel like there's a lot of
inclusion in spirituality there's a lot
of understanding and um it's very
open-minded and i think that it's kind
of uh
a different path than religion organized
religion that can feel pretty regimented
and it's kind of one way and that's the
way it is and you believe these things
and so
um i that's why i call it like it's
really about growth and um
so you're gonna you're really never
gonna i don't think you'll ever stop
that so i'm what i'm going to tell you
is not going to
deter your deter you
because you've already seen the
beautiful benefits and there's always
beautiful benefits but here's the
problem is it ends up going you have to
go through like
um really big growth periods where it's
uh
growing pains and there's always going
to be pain with growth
and um and there is going to be
like what i like to call like an
alchemization of old energy like it has
to burn down to the ground before it can
be born again into something new and
that burning it down is really painful
and so a lot of the things that are
painful include looking at ourselves in
a much much much more
deep and meaningful and intentional way
and accountable
like that's probably the thing that's
changed the most for me in my life is
the accountability that i have for
myself how i show up my reactions um and
it's just like a never-ending journey um
but
but what i was gonna say is on instagram
how they have what we thought the
spiritual journey would look like and
it's like kittens and rainbows and it
looks so great and then what the
spiritual journey is really like and it
has like someone that's super distraught
like makeup down their face and their
hair is a mess and there's like kleenex
box next to them because i've gone
through iterations of really big burning
down of certain things and
realizations of things that are going on
because you know it really forces you to
look at the truth of what's going on in
situations to realize and and and the
truth will come through and so sometimes
it's like
and i think in a lot of situations with
a lot of people they kind of stay right
stay in the same place and don't change
a lot and don't grow so there tends to
not be these burned down fear periods
there's not these growth spurts these
pains because nothing's changing so it's
all just kind of status quo
but once you're on the journey it's it's
it's gonna keep going and i was just
listening to a podcast uh with lewis
howes and and and i can't remember i
think shefali dr shafali is her name um
and she was talking about having her own
sort of you know newfound sort of
realization and she's in her 40s with
kids and it just happened and she's been
doing meditation retreats since she was
21 so like you know that's a pretty long
journey and it's kind of surprising that
you're still going to have these really
really big growth spurts where you know
it takes a lot of pain to go through
what you needed to go through to realize
something
so it's never going to end but i mean
that's i mean that's the truth of it but
there's always going to be so much light
on the other side is it's about um
filling in these gaps that were there
and like healing these wounds and so a
lot of i think what comes through the
spiritual path is also um since it's so
internal and so reflective
is the um
is the is the journey of uh healing
traumas
and we've talked a lot about that this
weekend about
just
how much our family affects our reality
and our programming our reactions
what we think is normal and so i'm
curious if you know i know you've talked
a little bit about your mom but is there
any other aspects that have shown up
maybe kids or any other kind of things
that have shown up for you that are like
starting to kind of flash red lights
like there's something going on here and
i'm probably gonna have to address
this
barking or like repetitious thought of
like
a thing
well something that i
my mom and i our relationship has always
struggled and
in past years i felt so much blame
towards her where you just feel like you
shouldn't have you should have grown you
should have expanded you should have
worked on these things and not passed
them on to your children and
then as you begin to grow
and you begin to hold up the mirror in
front of your face
and as you're talking it's coming back
and you're thinking wow i'm just talking
about what i hate about myself
not what i hate about this person and i
think people on social media do that
constantly
it was like okay actually you have to
take responsibility for who you are as a
person
you
were raised a certain way
and you went through experiences for a
reason
now it's time to take responsibility for
who you are and decide who you want to
be moving forward
and
it's easy to place blame and be mad and
be frustrated but it's a lot harder to
actually change and work on yourself
and so i had to start
facing that reality it's pretty humbling
yes
and you know another one that i've
talked about on my podcast and talked
about with different friends and with
you is
marriage is so freaking hard and as you
grow and you change if that person is
not willing to grow and change they
don't have to grow and change like you
but if they're not willing to evolve and
grow
it's like wait is this marriage working
is this gonna work and i've had those
moments with my husband of
wait are are we gonna be able to work
out because
i feel like i'm on this upward
trajectory where i'm getting happier and
things are blossoming and i'm excited
about life and i don't feel like you are
so how are we going to get to that same
page because i need i need that high
vibration yeah that high energy totally
you don't have to be the same person as
me you don't have to have a good day
every day but i want to see up and up
moving forward and that vibration
increasing over and over and over as we
lift each other up and then you raise my
vibration and you i raise did you ever
feel that before i'm curious if you felt
like the energy like were you feeling
vibration were you feeling energy didn't
know what to call it or is this
something that's becoming a little bit
more obvious now that you're having some
more heightened awareness around
attitudes and accountability always the
energy yeah i always understood energy
and how i an energy would just someone's
energy would just suck the life out of
me or an energy in a room would just
make me feel really uncomfortable and so
i always understood when my husband was
going through his own struggles how much
his energy would suck the energy out of
me especially if he woke up in a bad
mood having a bad day that energy would
be really pulled out and i would try to
lift up his energy and then i got to the
point where i was like am i gonna be
able to continue to lift you up if you
don't want to do that so as i got onto
this spiritual journey and heard more
about frequency and vibration i was like
oh now you're speaking my language girl
yes then i was like okay this makes
sense yep and i even told him that i was
like dude you gotta increase that
[ __ ] vibration man you gotta work on
it yourself i can only help you so much
and you can only help me so much and so
those are some of those struggles that
i've gone through with my mom and with
marriage and
i
we talked about this i wish people would
talk more about
struggles in marriage because marriage
is really hard partnerships are really
hard relationships are really hard yeah
people don't talk about that right and
they're hard because we're seeing
ourselves
like that's like the i think that's part
of what the hardest thing is is that
you know when you you know you say
holding up the mirror but really it's
like they are the mirror yeah
everybody's the mirror that person that
cuts you off is the mirror yeah that
person that um did a favor for you as a
mirror the person that your partner is
the mirror they're all literally it's
all showing you you
because you're looking you're having if
somebody cuts you off and you're like oh
what a jerk it's like you know you think
so you go okay wait why did i get so mad
that he cut me off it's not that big of
a deal and you go oh because i'm
normally the aggressive driver and i
wish i would have gotten in wouldn't let
him like there's always a way it shows
up or if somebody does something um you
know if they're washing dishes and
they're like hey uh you know i
hey i saw you didn't do the dishes i'll
get it don't worry and that might not be
a big deal but you know your partner
might have done that and then you think
to yourself
you get reactive you react you you get
triggered is what it's called and so you
get triggered because when you were a
kid
you might have been in trouble all the
time for not doing enough chores and so
now you're defending your like 10 year
old self who was always in trouble for
not doing enough and you're like i did
the dishes yesterday i did them the day
before gosh just get off my back i
didn't do them today and like you just
end up realizing how they're just all
just showing you you it's like a real
mind trip it's crazy what i found
through this spiritual journey in
meditation is i feel a lot calmer so
when someone cuts me off in traffic or i
almost hit somebody because they like
stop out of nowhere or whatever
i before i would like scream flip
somebody off like make a huge deal about
it and now i'm like that was annoying
well you used to joke about that on
social like you you would come on social
media like this guy was a total dick yes
and he and like look i did i thought
they were really funny things because
look they're it's not that they didn't
happen and you're so like you you
delivered it in a hilarious way but
you've even talked about you don't do
that anymore yeah well you don't you
don't talk about it on social media it's
like it doesn't even you don't even give
it nearly that much you don't give it
that much life yeah that much thought
it's just like okay like and of course
we still get mad at things sure like
still get annoyed you're like okay
you're [ __ ] idiot um you're a
terrible driver but i think a lot about
people yeah but you don't let it okay i
get home i'm going to talk about it on
instagram like i don't let it consume my
day
and so now
when
if brian and i have a fight i'm able to
sit there and to look at it from his
perspective
and he's able to do the same thing for
me and we're able to say okay this is
how i saw it this is how i thought i'm
i'm upset and this is why instead of
having this blow up fight
and so it's almost strengthened our
relationship because i'm talking to him
about vibration i'm talking to him about
these books about this podcast he wants
to do akashic reading now oh that's
amazing so he's
wanting to
grow even if he doesn't totally get it
yeah and he told me he's like
you're on the spiritual journey and i
don't get everything
but i'm excited for you
i don't fully understand it and connect
with all of it but i'm really happy for
you and it's bringing you joy and then
when he sees when i get off the phone
with kimber in the akashic reading and
he's like
sees this light in my eyes and i'm
telling him this and i'm like this is so
crazy and this like i can't wait to
meditate and i'm going to try this he's
like well [ __ ] i want that same
excitement sure and so we're able to
lift each other up
when someone
is putting themselves like creating an
availability with themselves and an
openness with themselves so
my relationship with my mom hasn't
really changed but my understanding of
the struggles she has gone through that
i don't know about
that has really changed and
when i see her
doing a behavior i don't like it's like
that's okay
that's okay it's not being done to you
no and that's just your life yeah and i
could let it eat me alive like i have in
the past and i don't want to live life
like that yeah like i want to live life
really seeing the positives in life and
through 2020 we were pulled down so much
to only seeing the negative in human
beings and all this trash talk on social
media and cancel culture and
horrible things happening in our world
that it was hard to understand that
there are good people and happy and joy
and all these positive things happening
around us but when you open your lens to
something else and you increase your
frequency you're like wow
the the world is really cool i'm saying
hi to strangers on the street all the
time i'm making eye contact with people
i'm asking the grocery store clerk how
his day is going i'm putting my phone
down and like looking them in the eye
and making sure they feel seen yeah
that's like the biggest shift i've had
is yeah people just want to feel seen
and they want to feel cared about and
we don't care often enough we're just
you know like looking down on our phone
thanks hear my groceries don't say thank
you you know you just move on and i
don't i don't want to do that anymore i
want to see the good in people and
hopefully be the good and people yeah
and spread that joy to other people you
do you spread joy i get joy when i watch
you and
something that i keep hearing on social
media and this is like when you look at
your old self and you're like ah
people keep writing me and they're like
man i had to unfollow you a couple years
ago because you were so negative and now
i'm back and you're such like a bright
light you're so much happier i can see
the change in you and i'm like wow i
didn't know i was
that dark i you know i was just trying
to like be funny and
uh i took it as funny i appreciate that
you you maybe i can't follow
but that's true that's a such a so again
that so that's an example of them
showing you you like they're they're
they're the mirror they're telling you
like you've really changed and so it
gets hard to see as our ourselves but
they're they're telling you yeah and so
that just as much as we need to hear the
bad we also need to hear the good and so
i think that we um are always so hot
as people were hard on ourselves
probably as women were even harder on
ourselves at least in different ways
than men i'd say different ways
um and so it's it's important to also
accept the good yeah which can be a
really hard thing to
accept it because that's the other
that's the unique dynamic that if you
can't feel it like you heard her say oh
yeah you know and you just didn't let it
register like you didn't really hear her
you didn't really accept it it's only
once you can kind of give yourself that
credit of like but since you know you've
come a long way you know you orient
differently with how you talk about
people and how you how long you stay
stuck on something is that you hurt her
because you believe it about yourself
and so like it's important to use
evidence along the way as you go through
the journey as all of us go through the
journey when people start showing you
telling you the good things showing you
the good things that it's something to
also notice too because um
i don't do a great job at that myself
like i yeah kind of like oh yeah okay
you know oh yeah well that's just easy
for me you know and but it doesn't
matter it's all still stuff to boost
boost your awareness of yourself and
that's i've been writing back to some of
these people and i'm like thank you i've
done a ton of work on myself yeah or
now even
the positive self-talk i've done
in this past year when when i start
thinking a negative thought which i
usually start thinking negative thought
around my period when my hormones are a
little off i'll say something negative
about myself and i stop myself and i
start repeating positive things about
myself and i just keep repeating them
i'm not even like hearing them i'm just
saying them and then i forget the
thought all together and i'm moving on
with my day
and now
when someone compliments me
i can actually
take that compliment in and i'm like
thank you very much and i can appreciate
that compliment instead of being like oh
you know like ugh i don't feel very cute
today you know how you'd always of
course yeah say those type of things and
push it off because you don't fully
believe it yeah but when someone says a
compliment i'm like thank you i really
appreciate that i'm able to like take
compliments i'm able to take feedback
more when someone says something like
before like i would you know have a word
i i like wrote a misspelling in my blog
post or something and someone would say
that and i would like take it as a
personal attack and now i'm like oh my
god thank you so much for telling me and
then i can go change it it's like those
things have really shifted where i don't
feel like i'm being attacked always yeah
it's just i can take in new information
whether it's a critique whether it's a
new word whether it's a new experience
i'm just able to take those in
instead of thinking like
oh you just know it all you know like i
it's just such a weird shift that has
happened it's like a it's a it's a
doorway into vulnerability because it's
only through your vulnerability that you
can because that's the accountability
right like you have to kind of be
vulnerable enough about being
accountable you're like okay gosh i've
been a dick before which is being
vulnerable instead of being like what do
you mean i'm i'm like it wasn't my fault
they you know did that so that's like
not being accountable and its
vulnerability is to say like i'm wrong
or i've done this or i've come through
and so
i think that the vulnerability is the
part that i'm hearing is that um
you know you kind of see it in other
people
and it just
it's like it's such a powerful tool i
mean brene brown is like the queen of
talking
of talking about vulnerability right and
shame and all of that stuff and i felt
so much shame before for my body for not
being smart enough for not being fit
enough i felt so much shame and then
once you drop that shame and you open
yourself to vulnerability you're like oh
all of us yeah have these struggles but
how do you drop the shame though
how do you i mean in your mind how does
it feel like you dropped the shame
i started talking differently to myself
that was the biggest thing
when i would start saying negative
things about myself i would turn them
into positives and i would look myself
in the mirror and i've talked about this
on my podcast with people i'm like look
yourself in the mirror and saying three
nice things about it yourself but say it
don't just like say it you have to say
it and really mean it and look yourself
deep in the eyes
and it came from doing this day after
day after day and it sounds so silly and
so stupid and like cliche not cliche but
just like okay i'm not going to like
give myself compliments
but the more you start talking positive
yourself you change that neuroplasticity
you can
if you can tell yourself you are ugly
you can easily tell yourself you are
beautiful and you can tell your brain to
believe that and it will believe that
yeah we can tell our brain to believe
anything yep and we're a program after
all yeah welcome to the matrix welcome
and so you can reprogram your brain
and that's what i did was reprogram and
it
it just
i just i just think it opened me up to
understanding that all of us go through
struggles and all of us i
find these connections with women on the
internet mostly women
who go through the same struggles i do
and then when i talk about it they don't
feel so alone of course
and
so i was able to just reprogram my brain
and how do you expect people to love you
and accept you who you are if you can't
even do that for yourself so do you feel
like you so you i'm hearing you say that
you're that the love for yourself has
gotten bigger yeah do you feel like it's
opened yourself up to being able to
love more people and more things
oh my god yes
um
is that
does that open you up to wanting
children uh because you need a lot of
love for that
yes
something and it's you know
maybe i'm just
being tricked but
the astrologer saying you know
she told us
i don't know what your plan is but be
careful because it's showing an
unexpected pregnancy in your future and
i had just gotten off of birth control
i've totally opened myself up to
the idea of kids if it's part of the
universe's plan if that's you know what
is supposed to happen and i know i would
love a child
so immensely i know i would give it all
the love the amount that i love my dog
and
the and just a lot through to save his
life twice what i would do for a child
would be unbelievable so it's definitely
where are you hoping that the spiritual
journey takes you
i hope it helps me open up to
another side out another realm outside
of here yes whether you know that's
talking to spirit guides
uh whether that's seeing something
visually
i just hope it opens me up to something
that i've never experienced before why
oh god danica
i don't know it feels like a calling
yeah i don't i don't know the answer to
that it something is calling me to that
and so i'm going to go with it because
everything that i've done in life it's
been a calling so far and i'm going to
continue following that calling and
that's a good answer yeah i hope it
takes that somewhere
i'm going to say that that's your sort
of cellular memory you're
remembering because it's not that we
have to learn things we have to remember
things
and um
especially when it comes to that sort of
stuff and to me that's you sort of like
your higher self soul whatever you want
to call it is trying to get you to
remember more about yourself yeah yeah
those codes yeah that's like let's
activate those codes activate them
because i got to do that soon let's go
do it
thank you yes of course
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button